in case you didn't realize how people
are obsessed with you we brought tweets
to prove it to you take a look at these
do me a favor read them out loud for us
oh that's so nice um it says I just want
Jennifer Coolidge to
know that nine gay men are sitting
around a fire talking about her oh we
love you okay and then of course this
next one um
dragons I would love that now that
you're in the HBO family yes I love that
um but you know they this usually in
cold climates
no um
the Jennifer Coolidge Renaissance should
be taught as an important part of
American History I agree yes right why
not we should be learning about you in
college courses everywhere
whenever I stay at a White Lotus I
always have a memorable time always
listen obviously with the enormous
success of the first season you're Emmy
all these famous fans like Prince Harry
and Meghan Markle does that fill you
with pride or pressure
well it's over I mean there's nothing I
can do that you know it's maybe we were
filming right now I don't know it would
be different but you film it and you
have to sort of Let It Go so
um I haven't seen it I'm very excited to
see it it's very good you're very good
oh yeah that's fantastic well yeah I
know I I know you I know right
no
um you know I feel like we all know you
by the way Jennifer everyone is obsessed
with you you know that
I feel like I knew you in uh
I feel like I babysit for you I would
love that are you kidding I think a lot
of people would now listen we don't know
the fate of your character of course but
if you could choose would you love to be
part of a possible third season of The
White Lotus absolutely yes yes of course
of course I mean I don't know what Mike
has in mind but yes I was yeah well
speaking of three we are so excited for
Legally Blonde three and Mindy Kaling
told us that she wrote a very juicy
screenplay for you juicy juicy is how
she described it um what do you know
about what Paula is up to
I know nothing I mean I don't know if
they wanted to surprise me or something
because
um I hear about it a lot you know and I
heard that Mindy has has this amazing
version of of our next round but um I
haven't seen it I haven't you know
I don't have the call yet we're looking
forward to it yes I am looking up the
words of course Legally Blonde why not
she's ready to bend and snap again let's
go yeah
[Music]
thank you